this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode he's back looking at
some of the modded weaponry this time
the mod guns of fallout 4. right what do
we got here the butt stock is the real
problem here needless to say it is a
boot it's not even a shoe as the name
would suggest so the name is incorrect
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to fallout guns make sure to
subscribe as we've got three previous
videos on bethesda's iconic franchise
and for something a little bit different
in a future video we'll have david
rawlings a swordmaster of over 25 years
breaking down some of the weapons of
eldon ring you use a hammer like this
i'd suggest that you're probably not
going to have an intact back to make it
up the stairs right over to jonathan
strong want to kill something
so many humans not many super mutants
wow interesting design very fallout
appropriate there's very little i can't
see anything that is an existing firearm
park this looks like something that's
been invented from scratch which is nice
this isn't star wars so stuff that the
stuff that's meant to have existed in
the timeline that isn't from our
universe shouldn't really incorporate
recognizable firearm assemblies but i
like this it's got a it's got a sort of
ray gun aesthetic but also there's a
heat shield in there there's a
conventional iron sight and a gas piston
arrangement i like the look of this
let's see how it plays
okay so the gameplay lives up to the
name this says it's a gyro jet system
this being the original
gyro jet or the pistol anyway there is a
carbine version with a basically the
same thing with a long barrel and a
buttstock assembly on it so this is a
1960s concept for a very sort of cheap
lightweight rocket gun it's a
very simple
design with a forward hammer that drops
to the rear strikes the
the round on the nose to initiate the
rocket motor inside and then the rocket
accelerates
back over the hammer to recock it and
out the barrel so this is like a concept
for what would happen if this hadn't
been an abject failure and had been
developed into not only a successful
pistol but presumably a rifle and what
they're calling here a heavy machine gun
now looking at the caliber of the
ammunition they're depicting here that
seems fair that is at least a 50 caliber
diameter projectile the rounds are
not conventional case rounds as they
shouldn't be they should be their own
self-contained propellant with vents in
the back the only thing that's not
really clear from this is how it feeds
from the magazine because that little
mini rocket thing
is thoroughly embedded in that mag and i
can't see how it would
line up with the feed way to then be
initiated by the striker or the hammer
depending what's inside
[Music]
right so it isn't just a cosmetic skin
for the ammunition these are actually
modeled as miniature rockets with
fold-out fins such as we do see on
larger rockets the gyrojet ammo didn't
have folding fins it relied on
rotational stability from the vents at
the back this looks like
some of the um single use rocket or well
guided missile systems have that style
of folding fin that fold out to give you
that stability and we can actually see
the rocket exhaust on this thing as well
and as they travel through the air we
see a smoke trail which we would see and
do see if you watch footage of the gyro
jet being shot you'll see the little
tiny rockets trailing the trail
oh paul's there that's not cricket is it
anti-materiel rifle up the bottom is uh
decidedly unsportsmanlike behavior now
that's the weapon this is kind of
exactly what i expect to see in a
fallout game whether whether uh modded
or not so this is an improvised type
rifle that has been improvised digitally
we see this kind of thing in real life
conflict zones today not usually as
fully improvised as this they're
normally
modified from existing canon barrels
this has more of the air of scratch
built which is a little dicey with a
cartridge as powerful as 50 pmg or 12.7
by 108 there's a lot of pressure
contained in there those of you who've
seen the now infamous kentucky
ballistics video will be very familiar
with what happens with a round of that
power capability because normal 50
caliber rounds
shouldn't do that to a rifle but there
is enough room in that case more than
enough room in that case
to generate extremely high levels of
pressure
okay i'm seeing a couple of things here
one of which is a problem the other one
less so firstly there's a big coil
spring behind the bolts it's probably
meant to be part of the firing mechanism
it's very big and would be excessively
powerful for that for that purpose it's
certainly not for a return spring
because the thing is bolt action bigger
issue is there doesn't appear to be
enough clearance for a complete round to
actually fit in
through the ejection opening in order to
be chambered the round appears to be
longer than the ejection port and i
think clips through the gun limitation
of the of the the graphics and the fact
that this is a mod presumably i suppose
the other things with this are
ergonomics within which i will include
recoil the standard fallout rifle pose
is a bit close in for a rifle as long
and heavy as this you would you would
really struggle unless you were
incredibly built
to keep that on target so at the very
least you'd want an arm further out
along the barrel the butt stock appears
to be improvised from from a bike seat
or something matters more what's behind
the padding of the seat you know is it
attached to a buffer assembly of some
sort that that soaks up some of the
recoil or is it literally just a bike
seat welded to the back of the gun in
which case it's not going to be great it
will get have some give to it much more
important to the felt recoil is that
muzzle brake which it does have so if
that's correctly engineered that will
remove quite a lot of the felt recoil
it's also not really clear what the bolt
handle is locking into or why that would
be necessary
actually come to think of it it doesn't
have the the natural
slot in the receiver
of a bolt-action rifle it just has a
massive great open ejection port and
kind of invisible locking at the front
and also at the rear weirdly overall
though i like the design if i'm gonna
mod fall out which i don't
i would much prefer something that looks
like it came straight out the game and
this absolutely does look like it kind
of could have come with the game
just comment on the on the overall
aesthetics here this does have the
random strap around the grip for no
reason thing so that's a minus one from
me
however it's got skulls on it so
automatically it's uh
elevated for me the general sort of okay
the barrel shroud thing is kind of
pointless but it is cool and i like the
decoration i'm not sure what's going on
with the double triggers they don't look
to have guessing they're actually side
by side and i'm just seeing them in
profile very piratical looking take on a
very short side-by-side double barrel
shotgun i don't know what the cylinder
under the barrel is supposed to be or do
slightly unfortunate configuration of
the screw in the butt and the sort of
skull breaker beak is that it looks like
a dead pigeon because it's got the crust
the cartoon crossing the eye and then
i'm reading too much into it moving on
there is in fact a slight drawback to
this decorative barrel shroud which by
the way i don't think has any precedent
in
history for obvious reasons it would add
weight costs doesn't add any
functionality in fact it would make
loading and unloading more difficult
because you
can't as easily access the breaches but
that's okay in in the game because the
reload is fairly fudged anyway there's
no way for them for them to depict
extractors and ejectors of any kind on
any weapon as far as i know so it's not
like it matters
i'm kind of surprised that this thing
has sights on it quite serviceable site
i mean the the rear sight would be too
easily damaged that's one thing i will
say
right
what have we got here an m1 or m1a1
thompson with jungle mags that's the
least of this thing's problems we've got
a really weird well it's not that weird
okay so let's be kind so the
the foregrip the wooden foregrip of the
thompson has been replaced with a sheet
steel heat shield handguard that's
perforated that's a valid choice in a
world of limited resources the buttstock
is the real problem here needless to say
it is a
boot it's not even a shoe as the name
would suggest so the name is incorrect i
don't know why you would do that okay
let's be let's be uh charitable so it's
the apocalypse you've got the ability to
fabricate some sort of a butt stock for
this thing but it's not comfortable
you've got no
available rubber blocks or ability to
stitch leather so for a butt pad you
just stick a boot on the end of it
what's really throwing me off and making
my brain hurt is what appears to be a
sliding left side cocking handle this
being the
simplified version of the thompson it
should have a right side clocking handle
with a simple round handle like you've
all seen it shouldn't be on the left
side and it shouldn't be a weird
rectangular shape that looks very
familiar but i can't think what it might
be from and it's called the shoe mac uzi
nine well it's not nine millimeter it's
45 even in the game so i don't know
where the nine comes from don't know
where the uzi comes in i don't know
because there's no easy on this
so this one i've been waiting for in
fact i was keen to see it the em-2 now
this is
a really good effort but inevitably
there are going to be a few
issues with it it's been modeled and
textured from
available images online and there isn't
full coverage of the em2 available
and frankly unless you get hands on
something it's it's very very hard to
get it exactly right and that's true of
aaa developers never mind people making
mods so i guess first thing to say is
rifle number nine mark one yes that's
what the em-2 was adopted as in 1951 but
none were actually produced to that
specification which is almost the same
as this with a different
hand grip the mod is is based upon this
version which is an early attempt that
would have been replaced by a more sort
of
blended look the
game version has a sort of
almost tapered look to it it should be
oval
and it should be relieved around the
barrel i either should be a big gap
because barrels get hot and you don't
want to burn your woodwork and this one
has the barrel emerging straight out of
the woodwork pretty much the only other
external major difference of rifle
number nine because we have the drawings
for that would have been with a few a
few minor changes but the only real
glaring one other than this would be
this bit this is called the barrel cover
it's literally a bit of sheet steel that
covers the breech area of the barrel
hence its name and this version is the
version that's modeled sort of a cone
and then a straight bit well rifle
number nine had a much more streamlined
coverage but i suppose the point the
point stands that rifle number nine is
is a specific variant of vm2 that's not
rifle number nine and this isn't rifle
number nine but overall this is this is
a really nice effort they've done a hell
of a job from photos and it's just nice
to see em two in a game
[Applause]
impressive reload there using the right
hand which is what the trials manual
actually does say that you you should do
they've done a great job adapting the
adapting the game engine to this rifle
it's basically as you would do it not
per the drills necessarily but as as you
could do it put it that way
[Applause]
right the optic should not be magnified
this site the unit site it is
not
a telescopic site but the standard site
is really just a way to get around the
very short sight radius of a bullpup
bullpups place your trigger and pistol
grip up here bringing the long long
barrel back into the gun and making the
whole gun a lot shorter that means that
your sight
radius
so the distance between the front and
the rear sight inevitably gets super
short you can see how short because of
the backup sites which you've seen
deployed in the mod so flipped up at the
front that then gives you a rear
aperture
here it has the optical sight purely as
a replacement for a conventional rifle
site so this is better thought of as an
aperture site than it is an optical site
even though it's technically an optical
site
yeah this is a really strange one very
interesting aesthetic to it it's a
gigantic revolver rifle revolving rifle
apparently in 50 bmg but the center
round is huge even huger
than 50 bmg i don't know what that's
meant to be
and they all appear to function the same
way so we get 10 shots but one's massive
and comes out of the middle so this
thing has two barrels it's almost i
think it's probably the mat revolver
inspired there's a centified version of
the lamp revolver which has a shotgun in
the middle so on the face of it i'd say
maybe that's a 10 gauge shotgun round in
the middle but i don't think the sizes
match up the other thing about the mat
with its central shotgun barrel is that
the hat it requires both versions of the
gun require a pivoting nose to the
hammer so that you can switch between
your outer ring of conventional
cartridges and your center shot for the
shotgun there look to be two firing pins
modeled on the gun but i'm not seeing
any switchable hammer and the hammer
doesn't always seem to be operating very
unique looking gun calling back to one
of the most unique looking handguns in
history
i like this
improvise any improvised firearm or
craft produced firearm is going to look
appropriate in the fallout world and
this thing absolutely does it's a real
mishmash of stuff for once i'm going to
complain about the lack of tape on the
grip because there's one piece of blue
tape wrapped around there that is
nowhere near enough to actually make
that comfortable you would want to if
you were trying to use this for real and
i've seen it done you would want to wrap
tape around until you ran out of tape so
he had something vaguely comfortable
to grip let's see if this might actually
work there's a great big bolt underneath
that's
acting as
some sort of retainer for the cylinder i
think although
let's have a look
right on the face of it i think this
thing could work it's single action it's
got a great big hammer that's cocked
between shots it's got cutouts on the
cylinder for the cylinder stop that stop
stop literally stops it in alignment
with the next round the only bit it's
that i can't
evaluate but presumably is there is a
ratchet on the back of the cylinder
those angled cuts that allow the hand or
the pull of the revolver to usually push
up and rotate it to the next position so
the stop can stop it
if that makes sense the problem for you
as the designer and maker of this thing
would be coming up with the mechanism
to make that work but hey we have
flintlock revolvers from about 1680
that do this and they were made by hand
by clever people okay so the big long
bolt underneath supports the i guess the
barrel extension you might call it um
doesn't have a barrel but it's the plate
at the front it allows that to be in
place presumably the barrel could be
fitted it also acts as the pivot for a
swing out cylinder i'm starting to
suspect this is a real design that
someone can model into the game but
that's that's quite an ingenious simple
way to to implement a swing out cylinder
because otherwise you've got a quite a
complicated crane slash yoke arrangement
built into the frame it's quite
difficult to pull off one that simply
pivots around a massive bolt yeah that
could work
right so we have a very handy
demonstration there of the difference in
accuracy between this thing without a
barrel fitted to it and width so the
first group pretty reasonable at this
distance that would be quite
embarrassing for any for any sidearm any
handgun but um nonetheless without the
barrel it's a lot worse and it really is
like side of a barn it's what three or
four times the size of the group size
there i don't think at this range it
would make that much difference to be
quite honest i mean you're not assuming
the barrel is rifled you're getting
stabilization that you would not be
getting at all without a barrel you are
also getting a slight increase of
pressure with the barrel and gas is
building up behind it increasing
velocity making for a flatter trajectory
but at this very short distance like
simulated 10 meters or less i think all
you'd see is bullets striking sideways
from the lack of stabilization without
the barrel and the group size would
probably be about the size of the first
one maybe for both of them don't know
your mileage may vary this thing is made
from bits of metal
yeah okay so our good old friend the
broom handle various modifications here
the barrel has been made pencil thin
with inexplicable radial cuts all along
it i would not trust that certainly not
with 763 mauser which is quite a
powerful relatively powerful round this
is apparently 10 millimeters um good
luck getting a 10 millimeter diameter
bullet out of that very tiny barrel a
very thin low volume suppressor that i
don't imagine would do very much if it
didn't blow off the end of the gun
instantly and what looks like a 762
takarev mini smg magazine detachable at
least the magazine well looks to have
been enlarged to accommodate it and they
do at least appear to have enlarged the
frame to accommodate the detachable
magazine which mauser had to do for real
with the chanel foyer machine pistol
which also incorporated a detachable
magazine remember the original mauser
c96 was loaded only from the top so this
is this has turned
an iconic firearm into something of a
cursed one
what is this
this looks like a mildly cursed
m16a4
there's a weird attachment on the bottom
of the
handguard proportions of the carrying
handle are
off somehow the buttstock looks too low
i might be reading too much into this
and then there's a really weird extended
charging handle that i'm i would say i'm
keen to see how it works but let's see
and it's called the
m2216 play on the m16 i guess
i think i get this so all of the changes
including the ludicrous charging handle
extension appear to have been done to
make fallout 4's
reloading animations and and grasping
animations i suppose
work with an m16a4 and the same
presumably applies to that slightly
distorted carry handle sight arrangement
as well in order to get the sights to
line up
behind the player character's eye i
would guess so the hand grip alteration
is so that something so that the gun
isn't floating in mid-air the cocking
handle extension is so that the
character is cocking it in a way that
makes any kind of sense and i think the
altered rear sight is also to do with
engine limitations which
explains why this is otherwise a nicely
faithful rendition of an m16a4 somewhat
compromised by well the compromises
i want to give some context to this one
do you remember when we did the fallout
4 base game
yeah there was the assault rifle which
was a mishmash of louis gunn and
m249
this is an effort that someone's
made to redesign the fallout for assault
rifle
into something
that makes better use of those parts and
angles and
create something a little less cursed
yeah
um what i think we have here although my
memory of the automatic rifle thing from
from formula 4 is is thankfully quite
dim is actually a a mod uncursing a gun
to some extent it's an alternate 1950s
ish lmg with with a drum slash belt box
feed it makes much more sense than
the original
gun from the game
the only thing wrong with this now i
think is probably the case ejection
which is a very minor thing to pick up
but uh that's what i do somehow the the
spent cases are ejecting out to the side
slightly and then immediately straight
up in the air um i don't know if there's
meant to be a deflector but there's
nothing there that would cause that
effect that might be a limitation of the
gun it's modded from thinking about it
but yeah i like the overall look it's a
chunkier wooden furniture take on an fn
machine gun
now i just wanted to
say thanks and a special shout out to
joe joe i gather from your dad that
you've been inspired to a possible
future career by watching our videos i
can't tell you how pleased and excited
that makes me that's why we do
what we do so i wish you all the best in
your future career whatever it is that
you you decide that you want to do and
thank you for watching and keep watching
take care
[Music]
[Music]
you